new at 11 all of those stabbings were  not far from the campus of UNLV which  has students and others who live in the  area concerned about their safety  although those stabbings took place in  close proximity University Police  maintained the campus is a safe place  we are well aware of what happens in our  surrounding community and how it might  impact us but generally speak  are an island of safety and we take  great pride in providing that service  Officer Vasquez adds that University  Police will try to be proactive moving  forward even considering additional  plain clothes officers to increase their  surveillance